earlier this year tamar braxton's life
was spinning out of control
and in this exclusive clip from taraji p
henson's new facebook watch show
tamar reveals what she was thinking when
she tried to commit suicide
can we talk about your beautiful son
we know take your time logan was
the reason why i made that decision
i just felt like he deserved better yeah
i felt like i was embarrassing him being
a fool on tv you thought he would be
better without
in that moment tamar's emotional
conversation with taraji was filmed
at the end of november four months after
the 43 year old
attempted to take her own life what's
the emergency uh my girlfriend is not
responding
i didn't want him to be embarrassed in
front of his friends yeah
right right right right mouth ghetto
mama
the mom to seven-year-old logan calls
that day in july
the lowest point of her life she was
found unconscious by her then boyfriend
at a los angeles hotel
about nine hours after the drama filled
trailer for tamar's new show
get your life dropped
[Music]
i'm not sure if this
is the best television
situation or the absolute worst
i need admit it because i knew that's
that's not what my whole life really was
that's not who i was
tamar also opens up about her struggles
with her sisters
and her ex on monday's new episode of
peace of mind with taraji
the show tackles tough topics relating
to mental health
i love that she felt safe enough to come
here with us
because she anybody that comes here they
are safe
because the thing about it is i'm not
some celebrity that just slapped my name
on this talk show right i am literally
struggling
myself i just want to hug you baby come
here
so how is tamar doing now well she says
she's sober
and working on her sound mind and body
i'm one of those women we never give up
we do whatever it takes
it's like everything is hard but nothing
is too hard we figure it out
look tamar is figuring it out and by the
way she also has a podcast called
under construction which seems like a
perfect title for somebody who's
rebuilding their life